clixoom nimmt seine gäste in die mangel
versehen mit einem pulsmesser bekommen
sie ausschließlich unbequeme fragen
gestellt wie reagiert ihr puls jetzt
unter druck premierengast summerjam
kommt eher selten vor dass ich nicht
vielleicht wenn man meine haare nicht
liegen oder so und sagen wie du hast du
dein halten ist schön gemacht aber
ansonsten gibt es nicht viel kritik
hertz beef oder der größte beef war
wahrscheinlich der mit riesen ein alter
rapper der jetzt nicht mehr rapper ist
und
das war das größte
fliegenklatsche kennen die einen oder
anderen wurde die schläge entsetzt
es war er um sportliche neben aber
natürlich irgendwie ein paar wenn es
kommt halt darauf an es gibt einige
einige aussagen die nimmst du dann sie
sind ja natürlich aus der luft gegriffen
weil er mich auch nicht kennt aber man
könnte natürlich das eine oder andere
persönliche nehme ich hab's aber im
großen und ganzen eher sportlich
betrachtet und den herren sportlich
eliminiert
sucht euch einen anderen feind bitte ist
es die falsche summerjam sei aber die
falsche baustelle wenn ihr gerade ein
aufstrebender künstler sein und nicht
vorzeitig eure karriere beenden wollten
dann sucht euch einen anderen sucht euch
einen schwachen 1 nicht so wortgewandten
gegner dem er vielleicht ein würdiger
gegner sein können aber bei mir wie
gesagt es sind fliegen die haben eine
windschutzscheibe
ich weiß nicht spannend jemand über vier
briten wird aber es gibt einige rapper
da draußen die wären froh wenn sie in
fiat hätten deshalb könnte auch mal
vorkommen wenn denn diese rapper dann
irgendwann mal werden dass sie dann über
wir drücken können
über leicht
nein es gibt natürlich grenzen aber ich
tue sehr viel für die karriere
aber es gibt grenzen
jetzt mittlerweile ich wirklich
kriminell
es ist auf jeden fall nicht
mehr so auf dem höchsten level ich hab's
nicht mehr nötig einen guten anwalt
ich habe den leuten nicht mehr um es mal
verklagt die leute einfach
spaß
mit allen dreien also auf jeden fall
meine drei spezialgebiete ganz besonders
mit dem bargeld mit dem baukasten
bisschen weniger und ganz ganz viel mit
dem ball
mir alles so leid weiters gibt es auch
mein erster
versuch in die selbstständigkeit wo ich
40.000 euro in den sand gesetzt habe
und das beste ist auf dem markt
weil man leute wirklich
musik wollen die schon die zukunft
dominieren werden
dann sollten die sich auf jeden fall
meine songs
sonst gerade erst an
die nächsten jahre sind schon geplanten
da kommt noch einiges auf mich zu
nächstes jahr sind zwei toren geplanten
schnitt schon fest ein weiteres album
und noch ein projekt über das ich jetzt
gerade gesprächen kann das weiterhin
bin ich im textilbereich interessiert
und
eventuell könnte auch was passieren
er habe das letzte halbe jahr auf jeden
fall feedback auf mich in meine person
und insbesondere auf meine karriere
bekommen und das war durchaus positiv
und daher mache ich mir keine großen so
ich bin am greifen
denn wenn ich schwimme im geld dann
kaulig also brustschwimmen eher weniger
ich bin eher der crawler und tauchen
durch gerne manchmal den geld manchmal
in anderen dingen aber oftmals in geld
ja deutschland deutschland wenn euch das
ihr gefallen hat dann geht ihr auf
hometown dort gibt es noch mehr von mir
oder abonniert den bingern channel wo es
ganz ganz viele andere videos gibt zum
einen sensationellen album covers
barbies um pagel